be proud that everybody calls it know
that you complain thank you very much
thank you let's start with your
questions now Thomas Meyer first can you
show yourself to us
yeah Thomas we haven't standard
president hit its way for our president
two questions
you talked about your travels
mr. hire echoed those comments here
there's been a debate in Europe why
you've been gone in the country with
where there's EU presidency the
vice-chancellor strata in facebook said
that the e C problems in NATO and the
NATO something to do with your back
troubles and you should resign he said
you are the laughingstock of Europe now
have you been contacted by the Austrians
has the Austrian Prime Minister
apologized for the comments of but from
his vice and what do you say about all
that now second question is on the
investment plan and the future 40 years
ago the EU with Airbus set up an
industrial project what could you think
of in terms of a new big project for
Europe in the years to come thank you
very much also to your first question I
follow things in Austria it's amazing
how many people are experts on my
medical condition I've read what people
said yeah I had a cramp in my leg
I was at the NATO meeting but there were
far more important things to concentrate
on than my state of health I mean quite
frankly I don't have time for such petty
phony nonsense on the major of the major
print you cannot simply say where is the
the replica for for Evers this is cannot
simply be defined ex cathedra but I
believe indeed that Europe must invest
into its role in in the world it's its
competitiveness means develop new
products new technologies and really
enter a new age I think the support for
disruptive technologies will be at the
core of the innovation and modernization
activities of the next decade and I'm
sure there will be projects that will
then emerge and become big
the problem with intelligent new
developments in in Europe is very often
that we in Europe have the best ideas in
small companies sometimes in offsprings
from universities and what wherever and
then when it comes to market maturity of
these products we don't have the
capacity to make such a company big
development like of companies like we
see have seen in the Silicon Valley over
the last decades are very seldom in
Europe and I think we must get there and
bring about the necessary financing
schemes in order to give these companies
the chance before our best new ideas
will be bought up by competitors from
Asia or America and we should strengthen
our own competitiveness by giving these
companies a chance in Europe so I can't
identify the the product and say we will
set up the new search machine in Europe
and bring it to a real challenge to to
Google although we're trying it but I
think one needs to think of this
direction we need to think a big and B
[Music]
modernization of our industries
societies and the companies I had
horrible arrow here on the
left thank you very much you're active
it's a question on well related to the
investment investment project for sure
him because the fact that you are here
with us president means that deeds you
want to highlight these rich in the
studied as part of your legacy which
will be part of course of the debate
after the summer break and we are we are
detained this pre election mode but
another factor that will have an impact
on your legacy is Donald Trump and since
you're gonna meet with him next week
what I would like to know is whether you
intend to have I can see overall
conciliatory approach with him to prove
that Europe is not an enemy or you will
rather be assertive two different
European interest on European honor I
don't care about my legacy the legacy is
like a poem it's crystal clear speaking
for itself I was in China on Monday in
Japan on Tuesday today here I didn't see
a but during this two and three days and
we concluded the largest trade agreement
we have ever concluded the one with
Japan and I have to say I'm very proud
of that because when I started here all
of my colleagues all of the experts were
saying don't touch this issue because
you will fail we didn't fail this is due
to the involvement the deep involvement
of the japanese prime minister who was
as committed to this goal as i was we
were supported by the President of the
European Council who was on the trip and
I know that I will be working the next
Wednesday but as far as you are not
present the US I would like to reserve
my remarks on these issues to was you
the last year's have a meeting in Canada
because then I repeated in front of the
best president European arguments and I
will repeat him again
and again it's not about fake news it's
about objective facts okay Dula on what
Pascal made oh yes president
I'm over here still about your meeting
with Donald Trump everyone's understood
Americans outside Europeans have woken
up after the NATO summit don't Trump
doesn't pay any attention to Europe he's
not interested in blocks of allies he's
interested in bilateralism
that's the geopolitical context my
question is this how long is Europe
going to be sort of tottering along and
how long are we going to kowtow to a
partner who's no longer a partner well
no we have woken up we reacted to
unilateral measures from the American
administration and we will give tit for
tat there's a point I'd like to make
directly to the presidents of the US
when we're talking about trade the EU
and it's single market is indivisible
the Commission has the job to be
involved in allowing Europe to
thrive bilateralism words work he is not
going to divide us and rule us
we represent the European Union I think
the European Union should stand shoulder
to shoulder I'm off there and relaxed
about it we have time for one question
yes Lawrence first the AIB is in the
process of sorry Lauren Lawrence no in
the Wall Street Journal the IB is in the
process of having its mandate updated to
allow it to blend more to projects
involving Iran but we've heard many
doubts about the wisdom of this from a
IB sources given the threat of US
sanctions do you expect the IB to be
able to make significant loans to
projects involving Iran in the future or
not and a question for president Younker
can you just clear up one fact which the
Commission has said about what happened
at NATO on Wednesday the Commission says
it was purely a matter of your state of
health and it did not involve alcohol is
that correct as well sir that's correct
this morning and it will be correct
tonight and tomorrow morning I'm really
impressed but in which some people are
taking in this not even marginal issues
and I'm asking for respect
president on your first question let me
first begin by saying that I have a
background in in foreign affairs and I
must tell you that the agreement with
Iran struck by the European Union and
several member states of the European
Union plus the United States and Iran
was one of the finest pieces of European
diplomacy I've ever seen supported by a
congenial foreign minister of the United
States of America and we believe that it
should be preserved so I've aligned
myself fully with the position of
counsel and Commission and Parliament on
this matter also as the bank however
when it comes to acting as a bank you
have to see the limitations of any bank
there is no European bank which is
presently able to do business in and
with Iran and as long as the financing
flows are the way they are it also
technically and as long as the EOB
mobilizes incredible amounts of private
money in order to finance projects in
the public interest and needs to do that
around the world and we are indebted
with five hundred billion euros and want
issues we have to take note of the fact
that we would risk the business model of
the bank if he would be active in Iran
so we must find more intelligent ways to
support a policy visibly here on in the
United States of America which we
completely share with the Commission and
the council and the Parliament but where
we cannot play an active role Thank You
this concludes our press conference more
important news coming your way in
shortly